i'd like to talk to you about the number
98 uh 98 is a b is
a bit large for people to think uh is
quite a cool number however you take the
square root of 98 it equals 9.89949
what i like is that the first two digits
are the same as the digits in the number
you were taking the square root
uh and this works for other numbers if
you take the square root of 99 it equals
9.949 starts with 99. and when i saw
this i saw 98 first i thought wait a
minute i wonder if there are other
bigger ones and it turns out there are
if you take the square root of 9998
that equals
eight
99.989
nine nine and there's your nine nine
nine eight uh and all these numbers and
you can keep going nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine if you square root
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
it starts
99.99 uh then four nine and there's
other stuff going out there but it
starts with those and this continues uh
the next one it's always a even number
of nines uh so nine nine nine nine and
then ending with an eight and nine nine
nine nine ending with a nine you've got
these numbers where if you take their
square root they begin with exactly the
same digit admittedly only in base ten
but i was just doing this in excel i
made a little spreadsheet and i was
putting in all these numbers and i i
found these and i wonder if there are
more and i couldn't find any more where
the square root starts with exactly the
same digits as the number itself but
then i went you know what i wonder if
there are any numbers
where just after the decimal point maybe
just the digits after they are the same
as the number themselves and there are
well i'll just do a couple the first one
is 77 because if you do uh the square
root of 77 it starts with eight which is
a bit disappointing but then seven seven
appears right there uh and in fact any
number
with
so nine seven nine seven and then nine
nine seven nine nine seven and this
pattern continues all the way down each
of those this one is 98 you ignore that
it then goes nine uh seven
nine
seven and then i think it's like nine
five or something uh but this here so
there's 77 there's 9797 this one here
starts nine nine eight we ignore that
and then you've got nine nine seven nine
nine seven and then a bunch of stuff
after that but there it is
i find these weird properties of numbers
fascinating and again i'd never heard of
this no one ever talked to me about
numbers where
the decimals in the number appear in its
square root i looked online i couldn't
find anyone else talking about these
sorts of numbers i asked some friends no
one had heard of these and i was like
well i've got to call them something
because i i was making notes on them i
was looking into different types and so
i call them grafting numbers uh because
you start
with a number and then its root just
grows off from it however up until now
they've been quite boring because
there's these two families there's the
the 98 family and then the 77 family
which is a quite predictable series of
numbers and uh i wanted to see if there
were more exciting ones so i thought how
am i going to do this and up until now
i've just been i've been putting this
into excel and doing a spreadsheet and
excel is great uh because you can see
the numbers as you're doing calculations
and you can search for numbers but you
hit the limits quite quickly and so i
thought you know what
i've been meaning to learn how to
program in python uh which is a
programming language if you've done any
programming i highly recommend python
you don't go through life without being
able to program it's a whole
area of a way of thinking and a way of
doing things and it underpins all our
modern technology don't ne at least for
a little while out of interest it's like
everyone should skydive once because
we're the first generation of humans
that can jump off that kind of a height
you know just a will we you know this
weekend i'm gonna fall from a plane and
survive right no other humans be able to
do that so i programmed a little script
and i found all the numbers up to 10
million
which appear
somewhere in their root before you go
past the decimal point because once you
fall off that decimal point it is a long
way down
it looks like it's stopped but it's just
checking bigger and bigger number see
it's found a few more and it's checked
the first
million at this point i'll show you the
ones i found so uh there's another and
i'm not going to bother with the square
root sign anymore just to make life
easier 764
uh its root is 27.64
and then 0 5 4 and so on and there it is
there 764 appears a little way in fact
seven six five does the same thing
two seven point six
five eight and so on and there it is
there seven six five uh
five seven one one gives you seven
five point five seven one one five and
there it is uh there and that continues
uh and the next one down was
five seven three six that gives you
seven five point seven three
six three a so on and there it is there
five seven three six
so these are in addition to the ones i
showed you before uh these are all the
other numbers that appear somewhere at
the beginning of their square root now
uh mathematicians can be very uh
patronizing towards some of the sciences
in fact physicists themselves refer to
biologists as people doing stamp
collecting
because all they're doing is looking at
things and just labeling them right
they're not doing any of the underlying
patterns or the reasoning behind it and
i
as much as i make fun of biologists i
also do like stamp collecting i like
biology for the record uh and in maths
there's some great fun doing stand
plating so these numbers
are meaningless to be honest this only
works in base 10
uh
that there's no rhyme or reason it could
be it could be a complete freak a
complete accident that five thousand
seven hundred and eleven its square root
starts five seven one one that could be
this could be absolutely no meaning but
i enjoyed
writing a computer program as such to
search through and to find all these
numbers but then the mathematician to me
thought what if there is a pattern right
what if there is something underneath
these and so i had i suddenly looked at
these i went wait a minute
this one here
seven six three nine four looks a lot
like this one here seven six three nine
three two one in fact it's the first uh
five digits of this and then uh
rounded up as such and then wait a
minute what if i take the first three
digits of this and round that up and
that's over here
seven uh six four and so it looked like
there was this pattern of numbers and so
i wrote a different program to just look
for numbers of this form uh and i'll
show you what i found if you continue on
this pattern does keep going the next
one down where we're up to gets to three
one the next one is seven
six three nine three two zero two
three that appears uh in its square root
the one after that was uh where was
seven
six three nine three two zero two two
five one the next one is seven six three
nine three two zero uh zero i'm actually
get this right zero two
two
five zero
uh zero three from memory yep and then
the next one is a bit longer and there's
another one a bit longer and a bit
longer and it keeps going and there is
this sequence of numbers that have the
grafting property
and i thought what is it and if you just
take this string of numbers it turns out
this string of numbers is uh
3 minus the square root of 5. if you
work out 3 minus the square root of 5 as
a number it equals 0.763932
and then it's exactly the same sequence
as far in as you care to go
so this family of grafting numbers
are based on this constant and so i
decided this i call it a grafting
constant and if you take that number
and multiply it
up
so if you multiply it uh well first of
all by a thousand and then round it up
you get the first one if you multiply
that by 100 and round it up you get the
next one multiply it by 100 and get the
next one and then so on you get there's
a whole family actually if you want to
write that mathematically we'll put that
in brackets
you're then going to have to
multiply this by
10 to the power of 2n minus 1 that will
generate your next term up and
in math to say round up we do uh what's
called ceiling brackets so i'm going to
do uh it's like uh i draw them like this
they're variation so it's it's calculate
that round it up next number and you get
a whole family of grafting numbers so
they are i was i was very pleased
because i went from just being
the the mathematical equivalent of a
train spotter pulling out these random
numbers to finding some that had an
underlying pattern and the constant that
generates them and that made me
disproportionately happy and this may
have been number four don't get me i've
not uh come across it but
most things in maths have been done
before uh i was at the mass jam weekend
which is the mass jam conference so uh
mass jams monthly gatherings and pubs to
do maths and talk about fun things once
a year we get together so 130
not mathematicians just people who like
maths uh we're in a room and i everyone
gets five minutes to talk about
something they assume everyone else will
find interesting and i talked about
these numbers
and some people
just found the programming aspect of
finding these and just just categorizing
them was was interesting but the
mathematicians in the room were a bit
more pleased when i could show that
there's a family which has an underlying
pattern to them and i don't know what
happens i've start you can look at them
you can do cube roots uh you could do
this in different bases like there's
always another way to generalize this
and see what happens
what do you think about this what do you
think i think about it
i don't goodness knows um
my my theory was that uh as a
mathematicians my theories are not that
unusual right because i figure if you
find something interesting someone else
will find something interesting and i
found these numbers interesting and went
well i'm sure i'm unusual in a lot of
ways but there must be some other people
who find this stuff fascinating and so
uh i thought i'd share it with them and
uh and some people did they thought it
was great and uh
it passed and i sat on the train and and
uh and learned computer programming